The late prodigy and his protégé have reunited
- but why?
Mere days after it was reported that Disney
and Sony failed to reach an agreement to establish
new terms of the deal that allows Spider-Man
to be a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Spider-Man himself paid a visit to one of
the most beloved Marvel actors out there.
Tom Holland, the man at the center of the
Disney-Sony debacle, and Iron Man star Robert
Downey Jr. were hanging out together on August
22nd - just two days after the world learned
that Spider-Man would be leaving the MCU to
remain sole property of Sony Pictures.
Holland took to Instagram to share a series
of snaps of himself and Downey Jr. together.
Shared in a carousel post to Holland's 30
million followers on the platform, three of
the four photos show the two men on a hike.
They smile at the camera in one shot, pull
some silly faces in another, and flex their
muscles and scowl in the third.
The final picture in the collection is perhaps
the funniest of all: it shows Holland and
Downey Jr. in a house playing with Spider-Man
and Iron Man action figures.
Holland's seen holding one of the armored
Avenger, while Downey Jr. is flashing a wide
grin at the camera and holding a Spider-Man
toy up to his face.
To top it all off, Holland captioned the photo
set with, "We did it, Mr. Stark!," which sure
sounds familiar.
"We won.
You did it, sir.
You did it.”
That's an innocent enough caption - it's just
Holland's witty way of saying that he and
Downey Jr. completed what was probably a grueling
hike in the summer heat.
And these are innocent enough photos - they
show two actors who have become friends off-screen
spending a day in sunny California, getting
some fresh air, and letting loose a little.
However, given recent events, some fans are
convinced that these photos and Holland's
caption means that the two actors may have
received some good news about Spidey's status
in the MCU.
The comments section of Holland's post are
filled with speculative statements - like
the idea that Marvel Studios president Kevin
Feige rang up Holland, told him Disney and
Sony went back to the negotiating table and
agreed to let Spider-Man back into Marvel's
movie world, and had him meet up with Downey
Jr. to celebrate.
Others seem to believe that Holland and Downey
Jr. may have had a sit-down discussion with
Disney and/or Sony executives about the Spider-Man
madness, and their after-hike selfies were
meant to tease that the meeting yielded great
results.
Now, we don't know the intimate details of
Holland and Downey Jr.'s lives, but it's difficult
to believe that the real reason why the two
are hanging out right now has much to do with
Spider-Man's recent departure from the MCU.
The interesting thing here, though, is why
Holland and Downey Jr. were in the same place.
Holland recently said on Instagram that he
was going "back to work" after apparently
taking some time off - and since Hollywood
is the epicenter of the entertainment industry,
it makes sense that, for Holland, going back
to work means heading to California.
Surely Holland and Downey Jr. would make time
to hang out when the youngster touched down
in Tinseltown no matter what, considering
they have a genuine friendship, but the two
are actually working on a project together:
Universal Pictures' Dolittle.
Based on Hugh Lofting's 1922 book The Voyages
of Doctor Dolittle, the film features Downey
Jr. as Dr. John Dolittle and Holland as the
voice of a dog named Jip.
Since the flick is set for release in January
2020, it stands to reason that the cast is
in California finishing up filming so Dolittle
can enter post-production in time for its
theatrical launch.
So, there you have it: Holland and Downey
Jr. are probably spending time together because
they're wrapped up Dolittle, not because
they executed a secret plan to storm the offices
of Sony Pictures and demand that the studio
squash its beef with Disney and Marvel so
Spider-Man can stick around the MCU.
Though the timing makes it seem like there's
way more at play, and Holland's cheeky caption
only adds more fuel to the fires of speculation,
the Great Holland-Downey Jr. Hang Out Sesh
of 2019 is likely all down to Dolittle.
And if it isn't, well, Marvel fans have
a big storm coming.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.